[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show as i garble my words
because this is a fast-paced q a episode
we're going to cover a lot and thanks to
everyone who is joining live we have a
lot of people
who are joining live we have people who
have submitted questions in advance and
we're going to cover a lot of topics i'm
going to
alternate between live and submitted
questions we'll probably do two to four
at a time and i'm happy to see everyone
here from all over the world and people
can submit questions
right meow in the chat so feel free to
type those in
and
specifically you can focus on
the general you can go anywhere you want
this is a topic free for all
and i see a question here in the live
chat
from clayton i apologize i'm going to
say l i don't know how to pronounce the
last name what worked best to help with
your plantar fasciitis a number of
things a splint to keep my toes
dorsiflexed
while sleeping that was one a second
was rolling
the bottom of my feet and also using
percussion devices
like theragun as an example
and
oddly enough this might sound really
strange because it's in some ways the
opposite of what i just suggested but a
physical therapist asked me at one point
because i was so sensitive
in my lower legs during massage therapy
during soft tissue treatment he asked me
do you cross your legs under your chair
when you sit and type i thought that was
a strange question but i did that i
would put my feet under the chair and
cross them and that was always
pulling my toes and my feet back towards
my knee and he said try not doing that
and see what happens he said are you
really tight in your calves when you do
say downward dog in yoga i said yes and
so i began experimenting with really
being mindful about keeping my feet flat
on the ground instead of crossing them
under my butt or under my chair and all
of those things seem to have contributed
mightily to the recovery also
not overdoing it with minimal footwear
the way that my plantar fasciitis really
flared up and became a problem is i
walked in
very very
minimal footwear imagine slippers or
moccasins basically on cobblestones for
a few days while traveling and that just
about did it so those are a few
recommendations
related to plantar
fasciitis and
i am going to take a look now
at
both the live chat and the
submitted questions i see one here from
amir or amber
gergich i'm guessing i'm sure i'm
completely butchering that name hey tim
do you ever do breathing exercise next
to yoga so breathing exercises
are something that i pay attention to
and most recently the type of breathing
i have done is in concert with hrv
training and you can check out
a doctor named dr lia lagos lagos she
also has a book that discusses hrv
training and using breath work basically
as the api to the autonomous nervous
system so the
what is it application programming
interface think of it as the gateway
into your automatic or autonomous
nervous system so you can use breath
work to produce what you would term
resonance that can affect everything
from the vagus nerve
to many many other things and i was
doing 20 minutes of breath work
twice a day for 10 weeks
and
my breath work tends to have
an objective in mind but i do think that
breathing since it is
this gateway into
the deliberate control which seems
paradoxical of the autonomous nervous
system or at least some of its functions
i find it very very interesting all
right let's jump into some of the
submitted questions
this first one is from the crazy
bulgarian what did you implement from
ander huberman's advice on sleep so
andrew huberman is a neurobiologist from
stanford university who i had on the
podcast and he gave me a lot of
recommendations related to sleep he's
really studied the visual system
circadian rhythm everything associated
with it and i followed a bunch of his
recommendations and it has dramatically
improved my sleep here are a few of them
so i did take his advice to get my fish
oil consumption up to the point that it
is at least one gram of epa
and there's epa dha contained in fish
oil among possibly other things and
getting the epa to at least one gram i
do that in two divided doses taken with
meals
before sleep i'm taking magnesium 3 and
8 which
selectively targets brain tissue or at
least is well absorbed by brain tissue
epigenin
is another i believe i'm taking 50
milligrams but you should listen to the
full podcast and other supplements that
i'm taking which i have to disclose
because i started taking them around the
same time and perhaps these are the
causal agents
quite apart from his advice following a
number of blood tests
it was recommended to me that i begin
taking and this is recommended to me by
my doctors so get your own medical
advice please i started taking higher
levels of b6 in the morning and
also in the morning i
began doing two things as suggested by
andrew number one
i began
getting outside as soon as i got up so
no dilly dallying and burning an hour
inside getting outside exposed to the
sun even if it's through cloud cover
for the first say five to fifteen
minutes of the day and i had been doing
this on on some level uh often jumping
rope for even two or three minutes
really just to wake up the system and to
get that exposure to the sun i've made
that a must do and i've also delayed my
intake of caffeine for 60 to 90 minutes
after getting up i think like a lot of
people my routine was to wake up and
immediately consume some form of
stimulant or caffeine whether it's yerba
mate or coffee or otherwise and the
point he made is and i'm paraphrasing
that when you wake up there is this
natural and desirable production of
cortisol which then does a number of
things including i imagine breaking down
glycogen into usable glucose and so on
and so forth and this provides you with
a jolt of energy to start your day and
that is an important
what they might call uh
well zeit zeitgeba are a time giver that
helps to establish a
a
bookmark for
the rest of your circadian rhythm and
that can dictate and inform your sleep
later so pushing off the caffeine for 60
to 90 minutes allows your body to do
what it's supposed to do without
supplementation without any type of
caffeine replacement therapy if that
makes any sense so those are a number of
things that i've taken from andrew that
at least together all of those factors
including the b6 which is individualized
so i'm not recommending other people do
that
seem to have really produced a change in
me so that i'm very grateful for
let me jump to clayton this is another
question that was submitted tim it's
been over a decade since the four-hour
body if you had to revise it what would
you change has your opinion changed in
regards to components such as keto
intermittent fasting multi-day fasting
pad etc
the four-hour body even though it was
produced in 2010 has held up remarkably
well and many of the things that were
first discussed or at least first widely
discussed in the for our body cold
exposure
and so on uh as it relates to fat loss
or thermoregulation
with raycronice and others have really
stood the test of time and entered the
mainstream so a lot of it holds up i
would want to take a second look at
polycosinol as found in pag to see if
there's any
additional research that either
confirms or disputes
the efficacy of including polycosinol
in terms of things that i might
add i would likely put in a more
sophisticated chapter on fasting now
that i understand much more of the
science and have done many many many
experiments and
had the input of say dominic d'agostino
and peter tia and various phds and
doctors
those additions however were put into
tools of titans so a lot of the
additions that i would have made to the
four-hour body were put into tools of
titans and many of the updates that i
would have put into the four-hour work
week
but more so the four-hour body and the
four-hour chef were added into tools of
titans so it's kind of a simultaneous
update of all of those books but
certainly fasting especially focusing on
more extended fasting so three-day fast
say once a month and longer fast seven
to ten day fast once per year i do feel
quite confident those convey
many benefits uh only some of which are
understood at this point
and last one for now from the submitted
questions before we go back to the live
feed it's from jordan why did you stop
gymnastic strength training do you think
you'll pursue it again
i hit pause on some of the gymnastic
strength churning
as you might define it as gst per coach
summer the former men's national team
coach
in part because i injured my wrist i
injured my wrist doing assisted training
with
iron cross and maltese cross on rings
and just felt this incredible pop in my
wrist and couldn't really use my hand
for a number of weeks maybe even as much
as a month or two that was my fault
so i'm not in any way maligning the
system and i've continued to use
components of gymnastic strength
training although some of the exercises
are not terribly portable because you'd
require something like a stall wall for
instance and people can look that up
hl which is an incredible piece of
equipment but you don't find it in very
many places i have however continued
with gymnastic strength training on the
calisthenic or bodyweight side so i'm
doing plenty of inversion training
otherwise known as handstands although
there are many different
variations form stance etc and
i am continuing with
developing active strength
and active flexibility in the end ranges
and that could be through doing
jefferson curls with say kettlebells or
any number of things like pike pulses
which you can also look up those are
found in tools of titans as well all
right so let's get now back to the live
stream
all right
dennis p whenever i have david goggins
on the podcast i would have him on the
podcast uh david goggins has also done
an excellent job of appearing on many
podcasts so i don't know if i would be
able to cover
new ground
and
that often gives me just a bit of
hesitation but goggins is incredible and
in fact
i had looked at david goggins back in
2009-2010
as it related to the endurance chapters
in the four-hour body but ended up not
being able to connect with him
in time to include something for
publication
all right
let's
look at some more of these questions
bear with me
all right this is from kale panojo if
i'm getting that right or maybe kale
punahou when you're learning about a new
subject you still follow the ds3 method
from the 4-hour chef given everything
you've learned about learning since
publishing any possible alterations
to learning i'm sure there are many
alterations but for those who don't know
the
the ds3 refers to
see if i can remember exactly what the
acronyms are at this point because it's
so second nature to me the first is
deconstruction so that's breaking down a
skill whether it's swimming or learning
japanese or chess or podcasting or
anything else into smaller component
skills
so identifying the elements that
constitute this larger skill so you can
break it down into
more addressable pieces then you have
selection that's the first s and this is
effectively 80 20 analysis you're
looking for the 20 of material or less
the 20 somewhat arbitrary that provides
you with 80 percent of the utility or
the performance and in language for
instance this would very easily be
demonstrated through high frequency word
lists some words are used more often
than others if you choose the proper say
1200 to 2000 words based on high
frequency by looking at ideally material
that reflects conversation but it could
be newspapers textbooks and so on you
can really develop conversational
fluency
or at least adequacy in eight to twelve
weeks in most languages that's that's my
belief and experience and
selection being first indicates that i
believe material beats method so what
you choose to study what you choose to
practice is more important ultimately
than how you practice because you can
get very good at efficiently studying or
practicing things that are of very
little importance all right so we have
deconstruction we have selection
then we have sequencing and this is
deciding in what order
to practice things so for instance
recently when i was
looking at rock climbing
and applying this lens
one recommendation that came up a lot
was fingerboard training but
fingerboard training can also produce a
lot of injuries because your
your connective tissue your tendons and
ligaments develop strength tensile
strength and diameter
at a much slower rate than your skill
and muscular development therefore
whether it's in power lifting or
especially in something where you're
using the smaller digits a lot
as in rock climbing you can really
injure yourself so as a
function of going through this process
and looking at sequencing i decided that
even though it was recommended many many
many many many times i would i would
push the fingerboard
inclusion to at least
say six months into my training and only
if i had achieved a certain level of
proficiency
technically speaking and then last you
have stakes stakes
s-t-a-k-e-s you could think of that as
consequences and that could take the
form of a bet with a friend
say for weight loss very very effective
it could take the form of pre-paying and
committing to some type of group
exercise whereby you are both
financially
benefiting from some cost in terms of
attendance and then also
getting the both encouragement and as
necessary ball busting from a group of
people if you don't attend and comply
uh i still use this with just about
everything so yes the answer is i still
use ds3 or dsss as described at great
length in the four hour shelf in the
metal learning section
all right let's
let's go
back
all right kl is just like the vegetable
kill there we go
uh
all right
regarding rock climbing this is from
jordan bourne great name
are you familiar with dave mccloud i'm
not familiar with dave mccloud m c
let me take that back m-a-c-l-e-o-d
he has written a few books on training
for rock climbing as well as putting out
a lot of good content on youtube i'll
take a look thank you
uh brian williams how is the work with
wolf conservation or how is the work
with wolf conservation going what are
the impacts of your support this is a
great question uh and this is a very
controversial subject it's called the
middle east of conservation by a lot of
people for good reasons there are
many issues with wolf conservation or
reintroduction
if people want to understand perhaps
some of the reasons for reintroducing
the arguments for reintroduction or
conservation
they can listen to my podcast episode
with mike phillips who led the
reintroduction effort at yellowstone
and i think there are many arguments
whether it's related to trophic cascade
and sort of ecosystem development and
people can look at a short documentary
called
i think it's called
how wolves change rivers or why wolves
change rivers
the only
s
sort of cinematography uh
mistake that i would point out is i
think they refer to elk and they show
deer or they refer to deer and they show
elk in the visuals but if you can allow
that not to distract you i think it
makes a good point
about how the
the absence or presence of one species
especially a predator that keeps
herbivores moving can affect everything
and uh since we also extirpated
meaning locally or regionally
exterminated the gray wolf from many of
its sort of natural
uh
historical range
if we're running into problems as you
would witness say where i grew up on
long island with rampant lyme disease
and deer overpopulation with no natural
predators i think there is an argument
to be made for introduction so
the work that i did if you see tim dot
blog slash wolf you can look at some of
what i tried to facilitate in colorado
and elsewhere i think is having an
impact on the national conversation
unfortunately wolves as a symbol
uh have become part of identity politics
and
uh they're they're they're basically an
outlet for
uh some
upset and frustration and aggression
that uh is most easily
applied to something that can be killed
easily like a wolf uh so we're seeing
i think
over harvesting and overkilling of
wolves i do not believe or i should
restate i do believe there is a place
for
uh
the management of wolves the culling of
wolves
and the management of those populations
through hunting for instance
i absolutely believe that there is a
place for that
uh but that
as it would be the case with elk or
anything else
they need to be monitored very closely
and those policies should be informed
and based on science
and
not based on
sort of
populist
politics and
it's a touchy subject
there is
an article that lays this out it's
actually very well done it's a feature
piece
uh called
the way of the wolf woman or something
like that might be wolf lady
in the new yorker so if you just search
wolf lady
or wolf woman and new yorker this piece
will pop up and it paints uh it paints a
very compelling
non-partisan picture because the fact of
the matter is there are
individual ranchers who are
significantly affected by wolf predation
on livestock
and there are many ways to mitigate that
with flattery and other techniques that
are non-lethal
but the fact remains that some
individual ranchers
really have their livelihood affected by
wolf populations
however as a whole
the effect on livestock and this has
been studied at colorado state
university and many other places the
effect on livestock over time is very
very minimal and i have some posts on
social that is sharing the research
related to that but again
these are controversial subjects that
provoke a lot of emotions and as soon as
we get into red line territory it
doesn't matter if you're on the right or
the left or somewhere in between it's a
big [ __ ] mess so that haven't been
said if you want to learn more i suggest
listening to my episode with mike
phillips
who's a fascinating guy
and you can check out tim dot blog wolf
for part of what i was involved with
and i have more involvement likely
coming so that is that is that
uh that was a long one
all right
let me
dive in
okay so
another live one this is from andy
donovan
tim you've talked about having kids one
day any thoughts on what you would teach
them at home which you would worry they
wouldn't learn at school or indeed
which they might need to survive school
this is a great question and
i think the the two things that come to
mind
immediately
are optimism and resilience
i do think that
the infantilization of
uh not just adults but children in the
united states handling everything and
everyone with kid gloves ultimately
produces very very fragile people and
if if the culture by and large wants to
swing in that direction
that's fine
uh but
i will want to ensure that my kids are
as resilient
and confident and optimistic as possible
and i think part of that will be
both loving them unconditionally maybe
what you would think of as motherly love
but also having very high standards and
encouraging them to try things that they
think they can't do or that they think
will be very difficult or they think
will be very uncomfortable and
that is how you build confidence
through competence you can't think your
way reason your way into confidence if
you haven't actually put in the time
and put in the flight time and mileage
to develop skills
and resilience under duress
you have to do things to develop
persistent and durable confidence
so i think those are a number of things
that i would focus on the forms those
would take i am not sure
but
i think that
there are many many good role models
fortunately who i know a lot of them are
coming out of military
and they've basically turned in a few
cases turned their daughters into hannah
if anyone wants to watch the trailer to
hannah h-a-n-n-a i'm saying that only
half kidding
but
at the end of the day their kids are
very capable very tough and very happy
from what i can tell so i'm gonna try to
emulate that as much as possible
all right let's look at some questions
from those submitted
next one is from brad patterson outside
of psychedelics what other somatic
experience physical modality has created
the largest positive shifts for you
i would say there are two that
three that immediately come to mind and
i'll give you
the answer though if i had to pick one
and i would say the the one answer i
would choose would be acroyoga if i had
to choose one
because of its effects on my
relationship with my beloved my
significant other because of
its blend of
mobility and strength in end ranges
as well as athleticism overall and those
are not automatically the same thing
sort of
adaptable athleticism is not the same as
being really good at
six lifts in a few planes of motion
and i think that even though this has
changed more recently i remember a
number of years when there was a
softball or baseball throwing
competition within the crossfit games
you can look at those videos to see
just how poorly people did who were not
previously competitive athletes in
multi-planar sports with rotation and so
on
so acro yoga
on top of that is just fun it is a blast
and you always end up laughing because
you're going to make mistakes and it's
pretty funny usually pretty funny when
you do assuming that you're being safe
about it and acroyoga is really
combination of
acrobatics acrobatic training which you
think of on some level as gymnastics and
therapeutics so it's also a blend not
only of the strength training and
agility and flexibility but at the end
of sessions you would also experience in
an ideal session say 15 minutes of
partner thai massage for recovery in the
cooldown and
you get very good at both
building and restoring and i think those
are incredible so i've learned a
tremendous amount through acroyoga
particularly in working with jason
niemer n-e-m-e-r look him up he's
amazing i've also had him on the podcast
the two others
that i would mention quickly
are
uh actually i'll mention i'll mention
three more um
gst says the gymnastics strength
training still component and i still
think there's a lot to be gained from
gymnastic strength training gst per
coach summer so mer if you search his
name in my name a bunch will pop up
the next is
very incremental
happy body training and happy body
training is going to sound hilarious to
a lot of people and it should but they
can look up jersey j-e-r-z-y
gregoric
g-r-e-g-o-r-e-k
his wife's name is angela
gregorick a-n-i-e-l-a they both have
multiple world records in olympic
weightlifting and are originally from
poland they
have devised a system of training uh
that is is truly remarkable and with
with what i might call micro stretches
where you're really only sustaining an
end range for a half a second or a
second maybe less
but doing repetitions with weight the
gains that i've seen in mobility and
active flexibility
through their program is
just incredible it's it's it's really
remarkable and combined with that would
be olympic weightlifting but i never got
very aggressive with it however
uh using as a training goal and as a
training
standard kind of the meat and potatoes
of some of my training in addition to
kettlebell swings the uh
overhead squats
became
an incredible tool for diagnosing
weaknesses and deficits to fix but also
really just developing overall
functionality so uh and that would be
overhead squats with a barbell pressed
overhead as if you were doing a military
press and then dropping down to an ass
to heels
olympic squat which also over time
developed
much more
mobility and flexibility in my ankles
which helped with the plantar fasciitis
that was mentioned earlier and last was
swimming i learned to swim in my 30s
if you look at my first ted talk
it describes how i used total immersion
swimming by terry lachlan who's also
been on the podcast so you can go to
ted.com and search my name and the first
the first
ted talk that i gave focused quite a bit
on swimming and that'll give you an idea
of
how i learned to swim and how it became
a moving meditation at that point
all right
john lamb is the next one what vacation
or place you've traveled to would you
most like to go back to there are many
places i love but the first two that
come to mind are italy
and taiwan i've spent
some time in both it's been decades
since i really spent meaningful time in
either and i love the people and the
cultures and the food
of both so italy and taiwan are two that
come to mind
and i'll do one more in these submitted
and then i'll come back to live
so the next one is joel cheruko
what are one or two of your super long
term big goals
i generally don't have
super long term big goals
i tend to view things as two week
experiments within kind of six-month
projects
and then i look at what windows what
doors open i guess it's more the
expression for opportunities don't jump
out of any windows but you can walk
through doors and very often i find that
if i if i apply myself fully
to
being excellent
or at least diligent
in an experiment for two weeks or
projects for six months like
experimenting with fiction right now
the opportunities that i will have and
the lenses that i will gain through
which i can look at the world and my
life
uh are things i cannot predict at the
outset so i i don't generally have super
long term but if i had to pick a few
things
and i don't know if these qualify super
long term hopefully they're not super
long term
two related to psychedelic science and
psychedelics one would be to
get to the point sooner rather than
later that the federal government or the
agencies within the federal government
like the nimh nih et cetera are
providing funding to scientists doing
research related to psychedelic
compounds on the clinical side on the
basic side across the board and
that is a significant problem currently
because since let's just call it 1971
the controlled substance act under the
nixon administration
once these compounds were put into
schedule 1 which means
high potential for abuse no known
medical application both of which are
ridiculous for most of these compounds
it was impossible
if not
at least close to impossible but
generally impossible to get any type of
federal funding for these studies which
meant scientists had to spend a lot of
their time
doing two things going to
philanthropists usually for small dollar
amounts which is incredibly time
consuming
secondly
they had to write
grants and grant applications for other
types of work unrelated to their core
interest of psychedelics
to pay their salaries and ensure that
they would be able to support their
families
while pursuing
this interest in the therapeutic
applications of psychedelic compounds
so they were spending a ton of time
simply to ensure they had a bare minimum
of funding to do small studies because
that's all they could afford the other
option in the last few years especially
so either high time low dollar amount
philanthropic fundraising plus grants or
they could take money from well-funded
for-profit
companies startups and that's not
intrinsically bad
but it's it's fast easy money with a lot
of strengths attached generally speaking
and rightly so if i were a company i
would want certain ip provisions i would
want maybe certain types of data
exclusivity and
that can get very squirrely and start to
look like big pharma lockdown very
quickly
breaking news update very exciting since
the recording of this episode dr matthew
johnson professor of psychiatry and
behavioral sciences at johns hopkins
received a u01 grant from the national
institute on drug abuse otherwise known
as nida to study psilocybin for tobacco
addiction it's the first grant from the
us government in half a century to
directly study a classic psychedelic
this is a huge deal and decades in the
making this has also been a primary hope
and target of mine for the last several
years and i'm super super excited to be
involved with the hopkins team so
congratulations to matthew and team
there are also some other folks to watch
very closely ben calmendy at yale and
others but suffice to say that is a very
exciting update since the recording of
this episode
so
uh i would like
these scientists to have a third
major source of funding which is the
federal government so that is one i'm
very heavily focused on and i'm hoping
the
initiative at harvard law school that
just launched which i'm a part of it's
called poplar the project on psychedelic
law and regulation
we'll be able to help with that and i
hope they will also be able to help with
insurance reimbursement so getting to
the point where these psychedelic
therapies are reimbursable through
insurance which means a broader
patient population has access because
right now
even if they're rescheduled and
prescribable the therapies will be very
expensive because you have
preparation you have integration you
have sessions that are say four to eight
hours in length all of this equals
expensive
so to make it available to millions of
people who are suffering with say
complex ptsd treatment resistant
depression etc
you need insurance reimbursement
so that is the second big one for me
and then last but certainly not least is
is building a family and uh moving into
fatherhood and
being a partner to
my
my lovely lovely beloved
and
i think that will be a huge phase shift
for me
and uh
tbd what that means but those are a few
of my super long term big and all caps
goals
all right let's uh let's take a look at
what we have here i'll do my best to
answer some more
all right
sheila mcqueen
i'm getting that right there's been a
lot of talk of experiential therapy
techniques like psychedelics
are there any promising research or
research programs using vr gaming i'm
not aware of them although i know that
there are some researchers including
andrew huberman who i mentioned earlier
as a neurobiologist
at stanford who have captured footage of
for instance great white sharks in the
hopes that they can take these type of
stimuli
and turn them into visual
representations in vr so that they can
study
not just fear
but fear extinction and contending with
phobias and so on
using virtual reality as a tool as a
modality
i think there's a lot there it may take
a while until the potential is
demonstrated definitively in some
fashion or maybe not nothing's
definitive
but uh in a compelling way with some
type of clinical study but i do think
there's tremendous promise and we just
have to look at 2d gaming to see where
it could go in 3d gaming or simulations
or therapies and adam gazzali
g-a-z-z-a-l-e-y
who
recently launched along with robin
carhart harris and others the
psychedelics division of neuroscape at
ucsf which is a very very big deal
adam with some of his previous research
he and his team develop software called
akili
and ak ili is the spelling and it
recently became the first fda approved
treatment for adhd
as software so i do think that
that digital therapies in 2d and 3d
and
in
virtual reality augmented reality will
be uh
certainly should be tested as legitimate
interventions and tools
all right let's check here see some more
so jordan chimed in there's a
psychedelic vr experience called trip
trippy it's trying to do something like
this no idea on anything beyond that
certainly there are going to be people
who want to replicate or simulate
the benefits of psychedelic treatments
without psychedelics themselves
there is a company called resonate also
that is doing some interesting work
in this space
and
take a look at that
and many others so this will be a
crowded and very very exciting space so
i do expect some innovation to come
through
all right question from brad patterson
favorite book from past year i read both
lion tracker's guide to life
which is a great book and brotherhood of
the screaming abyss good for you that's
a long one
per your wrecks and enjoyed thanks
well
i would reiterate that the line
tracker's guide to life by boyd vardy is
excellent that's a very short read for
people who are looking for something
that i found very compelling and very
short
the brotherhood of the screaming
business by dennis mckenna and that is
not short but certainly for those
interested in
psychedelics
and interested in the history
and the biography of not just
dennis who wrote this as an
autobiography but his brother terence
mckenna who is very well known thought
of as the irish bard of psychedelics and
was author or co-author of things like
the archaic revival
true hallucinations and many others
new books i would say that of
of wolves and men
by barry lopez
one of the best non-fiction books i've
ever read in my life it is incredible it
is just just phenomenal uh so i would i
would definitely recommend that people
check that out barry lopez also wrote
arctic dreams for which he won many many
awards his nonfiction is absolutely
incredible of wolves and men by barry
lopez that is the title the cover the
original cover is absolutely stunning i
have it in hardcover i very rarely have
things in hardcover that was given to me
as a gift and i was supposed to be
socializing and spending time
with uh my girlfriend's family in fact
and i did i did spend time with him but
i was so pulled into and engrossed by
this book that i started reading it with
every free moment that i had i carried
it around with me everywhere to the
restaurant to you know
to the park everywhere i just carried
this book with me so i would say uh of
wolves and men
by barry lopez
uh would be
my recommendation
and
let me take a look at a couple more
darcy leffler has a question since
moving to austin it appears to me that
you've become more reflective if this is
the case what brought this about what
has been the impact on your life
i think i have been more reflective in
the last few years and
i think that that
can be attributed in part to moving to
austin certainly but more so it's moving
out of san francisco i think that i
would have been more reflective
had i moved to
who knows
montana or pennsylvania
as long as i was outside of a major city
even though austin is a city it is not
one dominated by a
mono culture or a mono conversation in
the same way that san francisco is
dominated by tech it is pervasive it is
soaked drenched in tech tech tech
los angeles in many parts is drenched
and soaked in entertainment
entertainment entertainment and
it's very easy to end up in
not just an echo chamber
but
in a race where you feel like a
greyhound chasing that rabbit around the
track and you never quite catch it no
one quite catches it everyone has agreed
upon the rules
seems to think it's important and it's
it's a pull to the external in many
senses so by removing myself somewhat
from that environment
even though austin has a million people
or so in the greater austin area
i've been able to kind of recalibrate
and think about which interests of mine
are actually mine or those that i've
absorbed or inherited which
drives of mine
are mine
or simply
absorbed through osmosis in some
conscious or unconscious way
subconscious way if need be
and
i think that has caused me particularly
as i contemplate
family fatherhood and so on
it has brought up a lot of the big
questions where do i want to be and why
what do i want to be doing and why what
do i not want to be doing and why who do
i want to spend more time with
as
the sort of horizon at
the the vanishing point at the end of my
life draws closer now that i am at least
based on the
historical ages of death in my family on
both sides for men i'm past the halfway
mark
who do i want to deepen relationships
with do i want to deepen relationships
with people i already know do i want to
develop new friendships
and in either case why with whom
and
these are questions that take time at
least for me to explore properly and to
really think on and to journal on and to
test
also
so i think that it's it's been the
removal from a high density urban
environment with a monoculture or a mono
conversation i should note that even in
a rural place or a smaller city it is
possible to put yourself in
circumstances such that you end up in
echo chambers
so i've also been very deliberate about
trying to avoid that
and i hope that helps to answer the
answer the question i've also had a lot
of death in my family uh
my uncle just in the last few weeks died
of an alcohol-induced
heart failure and passed away on the day
literally to the day of richard nixon's
announcement of the
drug war 50 years ago
calling
public enemy number one drugs and
uh it just goes to highlight for me at
least
that better treatments are part of the
answer not necessarily better
punishments and
these have all caused me to pause these
types of events
periods of mourning
and so on uh so
whether i like it or not i've been given
opportunities to reflect and i'm i'm
grateful at least for that
let me take a look here
okay
uh here's one peter gronn i think
g-r-a-h-n have you ever been in any of
the scandinavian countries sweden norway
denmark finland and what is your image
as an american of these countries well
i have spent time in sweden in norway
and in denmark i've not yet visited
finland but i would love to make it to
finland and do some rally racing you
guys have some incredible incredible
racers and even some of the techniques
in rally car racing like the pendulum
swing is also called the finish flick so
i'd love to come to finland at some
point
what is my image i wouldn't say i have
an image
across the board of scandinavians
because in my experience i've found
norwegians danes and swedes to be quite
different
but i came away with a very very
favorable impression i've spent a good
amount of time in in all three
and
some of my blood is from denmark so when
i went there i remember i launched the
four-hour work week in danish i decided
to go to denmark i'd never been at that
time
and it was
hilarious because i was walking around
you know pretty much bald as is looking
as i do
and
uh it was like reverse where's waldo so
in japan you could like see a crowd of 5
000 people and be like there's tim
in denmark that was impossible i looked
like
90 of the people there and uh so we were
launching the four-hour work week which
i think is fiatima's
something like that
and where i was having drinks with the
publisher and the editor who is
responsible for this book
and i said yeah you know
but something something you know i have
this huge head and this gigantic bridge
troll forehead which i get made fun of
and have been made fun of forever in the
united states i have a huge head i look
like bobblehead in the united states and
that's part of the reason i continue to
weight train because i need a big enough
neck and body not to look like a
lollipop
and everyone had a bit of booze at that
point and the editor said
you don't have a huge head you have a
normal danish head and that made me feel
a lot better about myself so i have a
very uh
very positive association with
scandinavian countries
would not surprise me at all if i ended
up spending a bunch more time in
scandinavia in fact
all
right trey baldwin i loved your podcast
with jerry seinfeld i'd love to hear you
and steve martin talk i would love to do
a podcast with steve martin i don't know
if he would be game or not
if you were game i would love to do it i
think his book my life standing up
something along those lines is
autobiography i listen to an audio which
i recommend everyone do
and i did that a long time ago when it
first came out it is spectacular it is
it is one of the best autobiographies
i've i've ever had the pleasure to enjoy
especially via audio
so yes if
steve martin is out there listening or
anyone who is close to him i would love
to have him on the show
here's a question hey tim how do you
maintain the languages you've studied do
you have one tip you recommend for
language learners
yes
if you are working on multiple languages
well number one go to tim.blog there is
a
topics
languages or language learning link on
the right hand side and if you click on
that there are a number of articles that
go into great depth about this there are
articles by
ben the irish polyglot there are
articles by many others who have learned
5 6 10 12 languages and they talk at
length about this in my case i try to
create a chain
of
languages such that i'm reviewing a
prior language as i'm learning a new
language so for instance
when i
learned
when i learned spanish
and this was a long time ago 2004 2005
mostly in argentina
i chose one japanese comic book series
because a lot of the japanese comic book
series a have dozens of volumes you're
not going to run out of material and
they're popular enough to have been
translated into just about any popular
language
and
comic books are
by definition
conversational a lot of it is dialogue
90 plus percent of its dialogue so
you're getting spoken language instead
of written language so i chose one piece
which is a very very popular comic book
and i had the japanese version and then
i had the spanish version and page by
page they are identical and i would
read in spanish to the extent that i
could and if i came across something i
didn't know i would then go to the
japanese and i would look at the
japanese version and see if that
reminded me of the proper word if i
could translate the japanese in other
words so i'd use the japanese to
reinforce
uh the spanish and the spanish
reinforces japanese the japanese was
what i already knew the spanish was my
target all right then i learned spanish
pretty well my spanish now is rusty but
i can get by
keeping in mind this was 2004 2005.
so 16 years ago i haven't studied since
and then when i later in
uh
i suppose 2005 it would have been wanted
to learn german and i might be getting
these two mixed up actually it might
have been german first but nonetheless
the the illustration will be
uh coherent when i then wanted to learn
german i had the spanish version of one
piece and let's say
learning spanish i had gone from volume
10 to 15 right each volume is 200 pages
or something
then i picked up at 16
and i had the german one piece and then
i had the spanish one piece right so i
try to read the german if i couldn't i
would go to spanish
and if if the spanish wouldn't get it
done then i would go to an electronic
dictionary now you have google translate
so it makes it a lot easier and so on
and so forth so i created these chains
these these connected links of one
language to the next but i highly
suggest for those interested in digging
into this
i think some of the best articles
written on the web about language
learning are on my blog at tim.blog and
you can find the language learning
topic or tag and i can say that
comfortably because
many of the best articles are written by
other people
all right
vaibhav mithuku i think the name is what
principles have you learned from chess
that you can use outside of the game
quite a few and if anyone saw the
tim ferriss experiment episode where i
did chess and brazilian jiu jitsu
i think this this is a good illustration
and you can also find a discussion of
this
in the four hour chef there's actually
pretty extensive discussion of josh
waitskin his work with pendlefini i
think it was
and various principles that he applies
and that i apply in other areas i would
suggest if you're looking for the
translation of chess principles high
level chess principles to many other
fields pick up a book called the art of
learning by josh waitzkin so the art of
learning by josh waitzkin
w-a-i-t-z-k-i-n
he was the second or third ever podcast
i did on this podcast that now has
almost 600 episodes and every episode
with him i think is solid gold so you
can also listen to the first episode
with him
some of those would be
learning the macro from the micro so
taking or creating scenarios of
decreased or minimal complexity let's
just say going to the end game in chess
and having king and pawn versus king
to learn the macro principles that will
allow you to then become a better chess
player when all the pieces are involved
there are a number of others i'll leave
it at that for now but learning the
the macro from the micro with with
simulated
conditions of reduced complexity is
something that he's applied all over the
place to chess to investing to tai chi
push hands in which he was a world
champion to brazilian jiu jitsu in which
he
uh became the first black belt under
marcelo garcia who is considered the
greatest of all time nine time world
champion
and so forth and so on so those are a
few that come to mind
let me take
a look at some of these submitted
questions the intrepid guide
update thank you for answering my
question what you described as chains is
called laddering there you go
so it's called laddering there you have
it folks
all right so question from timer shaw
tim i feel often like my energy to think
deliberately is low how can i improve
this my recommendation would first and
foremost be to get comprehensive blood
testing with your doctor because you may
identify especially if you do
a
micro nutrient analysis
on top of that that you have some type
of deficiency or some type of
explainable issue that can be treated
it's not necessarily a thyroid issue for
instance but there are things like
hypothyroidism that
could explain something like this there
are many other things perhaps you have a
selenium deficiency perhaps you're
taking too much zinc and you've
developed in response a copper
deficiency right so over doing it with
supplements and drugs can produce
various issues
but
stop number one is talking to your
physician and getting comprehensive
blood testing
all right uh let me take a look
at some of the questions here
question from matt ridley outside of
sleep what is your biggest force
multiplier be five to twenty minutes of
exercise in the morning
with sun exposure even without sun
exposure i think there's tremendous
value and as soon as you get up doing
five to twenty minutes of exercise
that could be just about anything that
moves your body and i do think that
motion whether that's jumping rope
kettlebell swings something dynamic
swimming
is a great value it seems to really
turn on
my neural drive in a way that helps my
cognition and mood
tremendously for the rest of the day it
is astonishing how big a difference even
two minutes of jumping rope outside like
everybody has two minutes you have no
excuse not to do two minutes of
something but doing two minutes of
jumping rope outside in the sun
seriously if that's all i do it is a
complete step function change in how i
feel and how i think for the rest of the
day
it could be placebo i don't really care
if it is placebo
but that would be the force multiplier
outside of sleep five to 20 minutes
exercise in the am which consequently
helps with sleep also so it's a two for
one
uh all right
[Music]
mira levy what about cold showers first
thing in the am
yeah i like that too i like exercise
more but what i'll often do right now is
i will exercise for the five to 20
minutes and then take a cold shower to
rinse off and then move on with the day
so that's how i approach it
all right
this is a question from alex after
undergoing isolation stress and trauma
how would you suggest individuals deal
with the lingering psychological effects
and cognitive biases of the pandemic in
parentheses heightened scarcity mindset
risk aversion etc so that one can keep
making growth-based decisions as opposed
to fear-based ones
and there's more to it but i'll tackle
that first
so the first thing i would say is
the cognitive biases or frames that
remain
at this point
and i should say during and not after
the pandemic
because i don't think we are clearly out
of the woods yet
certainly not on a global scale
i
fear has a place and fear can be a
teacher
and we have evolved to observe and learn
from cues in our environment so
having a certain degree of fear or
apprehension or wanting to have extra
cash reserves
right now i don't view as a pathological
adaptation i think that is actually very
reasonable
so
while i don't think it's additive
probably or healthy to
sit in your house on the floor
rocking yourself
all day with the curtains drawn you know
if you have something like complex ptsd
i don't think that is i think that is
maladaptive
ultimately long term
but if you're simply behaving a little
more
conservatively because of what has
happened in world and local events over
the last year i think that's a very
intelligent adaptation so i i don't take
that to be a bad thing however
to
address your question
more directly i'll give you two things
so the first i think is to
and i've i've learned this the hard way
multiple times
rather than trying to fix or suppress
scarcity mindset risk aversion
anxiety
if you want to begin to improve the
situation i find that
reading a book like radical acceptance
by tara brock is incredibly helpful
if you are trying to block things out or
compartmentalize them or get rid of them
i do find you can do a lot of damage in
the process and the solution is very
rarely a long-term durable solution so
radical acceptance by tara brock which
was recommended to me at one point by a
neuroscience phd which is very
surprising
i think that book is spectacular
if you are interested in a therapeutic
modality a therapy that can complement
that or be done independently i think
ifs internal family systems
is exceptional and i've seen tremendous
results personally from that for that
reason i had dick schwartz or richard
schwartz on the podcast if you search if
you search my name
and
ifs that podcast should pop right up and
i suggest listening to that
and the last and this is this is
effective highly effective
for worrying and anxiety side note i
remember someone said to me worrying is
like praying for what you don't want i
thought that was
quite clever and memorable and useful to
keep in mind but the book is an old one
how to stop worrying and start living by
dale carnegie pretty sure i'm getting
the title right
how to stop worrying and start living by
dale carnegie i have yet to meet a
single person
i should say a friend i've yet to
run into a single close friend of mine
who's been suffering from anxiety who
has not benefited from this book and
come back
and been incredibly happy that they read
it some of it's going to be outdated
that's fine it's an older book
but it is outstanding so radical
acceptance the book ifs as a training
modality you can get a taste of it i do
a live demonstration of it on the
podcast with dick schwartz and then how
to stop worrying and start living by
dale carnegie
all right let me take another look here
at
the submitted questions
side note
[Applause]
finance and money for those who are
looking at the video you can see this
this painted circle looks kind of like
the eye of sauron it's this this red
circle with
uh a yellow and white center and
green on the canvas around it i have had
more compliments on this piece of
artwork from
people who've seen it than perhaps any
other piece of artwork i've ever had
this was bought for
60
at a warehouse
yard sale basically so
uh for what that's worth
katie wood
asks what advice would you give to
someone just getting started in
podcasting or what would you have done
differently when you first started note
i realize that very few people actually
can monetize their podcast in a
meaningful way so i'm not as interested
in that as i am in making something
worth listening to
thanks as always
you're welcome katie so let me take a
stab at this
what would i do differently i wouldn't
do anything differently i think i made
all the right mistakes
and uh i think i approached it in a way
that i'm very very happy with and
i'm gonna rephrase
something that you said though if that's
all right you said
and i'm summarizing here but i'm
interested in making something worth
listening to
i would suggest you think about
creating a podcast
by asking how can i make this worth
doing
personally from me
and the way i thought about that was
informed by conversations i've had
with
scott adams the creator of dilbert he's
written about this extensively and he
has excellent excellent writing and
essays on this but how to win even if
you lose and he and i also talked about
this on the podcast so if you want to
listen to that
you can find him there by the way he
also predicted everything that happened
with trump well in advance of anyone
thinking it was anything more than a
joke so his predictive powers are also
pretty good
but
the way i approached podcasting was
asking myself
what skills can i develop
and which people can i develop or deepen
relationships with by doing this so that
even if i stop after six episodes and
i'd initially committed to six episodes
i think it's important to commit to some
critical mass of say six to ten episodes
because you will need the repetitions to
develop skills and as a consequence of
developing better skills to deepen
relationships or develop relationships
with people
and i approached it as a
win-win
proposition in the sense that
i
enjoy researching and interviewing
people that is my favorite part of
putting together my books is identifying
experts interviewing them and pulling
out unusual findings that's my favorite
part of the book writing process i was
burned out after the four-hour chef
didn't want to
even look at a book for a while at least
a couple of years
and i realized that by doing the podcast
because i'd really enjoyed being on a
few podcasts during the four hour chef
launch specifically nerdist podcast joe
rogan mark maron and others some of the
longer form podcasts really enjoyed
being on that side and i thought to
myself if i approach this in the right
way i can become better at interviewing
and therefore i can become better doing
research which will help future books if
i decide to go back to books
i'll interview people initially people i
know because it'll be less intimidating
and they'll hopefully be more forgiving
although kevin rose busted my balls like
crazy in the very first episode because
that's kevin and that's what good
friends do
uh but i approached it so that
even if
i had zero listeners
it would still be a success after after
six episodes and on top of learning to
ask better questions in listening to the
audio i would be able to identify and
fix verbal text and by fixing verbal
texts like like um you know so etc etc
you become a better thinker
usually the easiest way to do that is
through writing is to trap your writing
on paper and then you can edit or have
proofreaders edit your thinking it's
very hard to do
in conversation unless you record
and you can not just record but you can
transcribe
so that you can review transcripts and
see just how awful your verbal tics look
when they are
put on the printed page
so those are a few suggestions but think
about how you can win
how you can be really happy you spent
the time doing it
and in my case that's developing skills
developing relationships deepening
relationships and an example of that
would be in the next couple of weeks i'm
hoping to interview my parents
i'm not planning on ever publishing
those i hope to share those with my kids
when they're old enough
but that's really to deepen my
relationship with my parents and also to
have
a recording of them
in
vivid detail and rich depth for my own
kids because my grandparents passed away
when i was very young i really didn't
get to know them very well
and that's an example of sort of winning
no matter what even if no one in this
case the intention is kids but even if
you don't have a guaranteed audience if
that makes any sense
okay
one more
submitted question then i'll go back to
live
this is from ivy patton any thoughts on
gap year travel all to ed for young
adults not in lieu of college
necessarily but as a way to better
understand yourself before the enormous
investment of a college education
furthering the truth that not all
classrooms have four walls and not all
people are cut out for desk learning so
perhaps the question is do you think
college is a must well let me back up
and comment on
the lead
which was related to gaap year i think
that
almost everyone would benefit from
having the option of a gap year in the
united states
and i would love one option for that gap
year to be national service of some type
that could be peace corps it could be
volunteering with a national nonprofit
like teach for america
could be military could be anything but
and that was actually suggested on this
podcast
so i've absorbed a lot from my guests
but i do think a gap year whether that
is traveling abroad whether that is
doing something in the united states but
stepping outside of the four walls of
the classroom to really gain
life experience that broadens your
thinking
of the world and the people in the world
is tremendously tremendously valuable
as to the question of
whether or not college is a must
it's hard to say that anything is a must
there are always exceptions right so i
can't say college is a must
but what i will say is that for
at this point in time for most people
if we're approaching it from a
professional perspective
the vast majority of people will benefit
from having a college degree
there are always these tales of the bill
gates the zuckerbergs
and so on who drop out of stanford or
harvard or wherever it might be
but there's some fine print on that that
is really important
those people very rarely drop out
they are not burning their ships they're
taking a leave of absence
many of these schools will allow you to
take a leave of absence and come back
and finish your degree at any point in
time that is not the same as dropping
out it is also not the same as not going
to college
if you attend stanford if you attend
harvard and you say i dropped out of
stanford i dropped out of harvard and
you succeed and people repeat that
you're still getting the benefit
of the blue chip branding associated
with stanford or harvard right so it's
important to recognize that
and i would be very skeptical of anyone
who has benefited a lot from a degree or
a diploma
if they tell you that you should not go
to college
i would carefully assess how that has
impacted their trajectory for instance
going to princeton help me it absolutely
helped me was it necessary
hard to say
but did it open doors did it allow me to
get replies to emails and so on where
otherwise i think it would have been
harder absolutely
so one could say from a professional
perspective i'm gonna come back to
the topic of education and and cognition
more broadly speaking
but from the professional perspective
you know one could make the argument
that if you can get into an excellent
school
it is more valuable than getting into a
non-excellent school i happen to think
again for most people a college degree
is going to be of great benefit whether
or not
it is a top tier school
when it gets to
mbas
and things like that
professional degrees
graduate degrees
if you are doing it for professional
advancement
let's take a look at an mba program i
think that the value of an mba is
dramatically lowered if you are not
going to one of the top
10 15 schools
in the country
who are well known for their mba
programs
that advice could differ if you are
coming out of a management consulting
job or
one of the big five accounting firms
within which
getting an mba
is encouraged for career advancement
promotion where they pay your way that
is a different situation
all right let's come back to the broader
question do you think college is a must
but now let's look at it
from
the perspective of what i would consider
in the most literal sense not in the
typical sense a liberal arts education
so this this again differs a little bit
in it from technical
uh degrees but i never received a
technical degree so i can't really speak
to that i do think that going to a
school
and
not going to say it's a must but going
to college
being forced to take
mandatory
coursework and then depending on your
department having required coursework
and course load
broadens your intellectual curiosity i
do think at least in my case
you end up taking things that you
expected not to like that you really
like you take things that you thought
you'd like that you really don't like
you take things that you thought you'd
be terrible at that you turn out to be
pretty good at
you take classes you think are going to
breeze that completely kick your ass and
i do think that broader education
with assignments how old-fashioned am i
are really valuable to someone in that
phase of life that being the age range
of an undergrad because you don't know
what you want
even though you might think you do you
don't know what you're best at
you don't know
where your life will be in two three
four five years
and
it is absurd to think that you have
comprehensive
self-awareness of your strengths and
weaknesses you simply don't and you're
not
cognizant of where you have the greatest
potential either
in that case i do think there's a
benefit to
college so to speak now could that take
the form of something online yes could
it take the form of something
in another format absolutely but
most people left to their own devices
without some
investment of time and money and without
the accountability of classmates and
having to be a certain place at a
certain time are just not going to study
as much as people who are operating
within those constraints
and constraints aren't always things
that prevent you from doing what you
want to do sometimes constraints are the
things that you erect or that you
deliberately engage with so that you can
focus
on doing the thing you want to do so i
think positive constraints are very very
important so that's a long answer but
ivy pattern i hope that helps let's take
a look at some of the live questions
miguel
laite laiche i don't know how you
pronounce that tim how are you going to
cope with sleepless nights once you
become a father i have no idea
that's one of those i'll figure it out
when i get there kind of things i don't
know i'm not looking forward to no sleep
but
if if my friends are any indication they
seem to adapt and not die so i assume i
will do the same
all right let me take a look here
jonas k do i know t time with tainan i
don't know t time with tynan you know
i've seen a bunch of tee times
people can look back at this podcast in
that blog post and see that i did tea
time with tim quite a long time ago so i
don't know what's going on with the tee
times
but i do think i was one of the the
early adopters to
t time with x uh so who knows maybe i'm
an imitator maybe unbeknownst to me i
have copied many many other people have
done the same thing i do not know
oh yeah you guys haven't seen the t t
the austin
that's the t
uh okey dokey
uh question what's my take on global
warming how are you preparing for
possible worst case scenarios i am
paying incredible attention to climate
change and thinking about it on every
possible level i would say
that it singularly is
what
produces the most
existential
anxiety and preoccupation in me so i'm
looking at it from every possible
perspective
and thinking about the implications on
food security
on
uh
migration within countries both in the
u.s and elsewhere
water supply
and i think we're going to have a lot of
trouble in the next 10 to 20 years
possibly sooner
so that is not a comprehensive answer
but i am i'm extremely occupied and
preoccupied with thinking about
climate change and researching it and
spending time
uh reading
about
the kind of latest findings and
potential implications from experts
all right
ruth ann
also that eight sleep pod has changed my
sleep life dramatically so that's
awesome to hear i've hate sleep right
upstairs
i am a huge fan
especially when it's
95 plus degrees outside had the ac die
and if it weren't for the eight sleep i
would have been
just an omelet with zero hours of sleep
uh let's see
question from jessica downey i'm joining
late so maybe you answered this already
why are you suddenly hosting these more
frequently what do these sessions bring
to you
honestly i don't get out that much i'm
pretty introverted and
very very very private
uh with my personal life so this is a
way for me to engage socially and have
fun
and meet people and answer questions i
never would have come up with on my own
and to also turn the tables and have a
chance to just riff since i'm the one
usually asking questions
so i get a lot out of this i really
really dig it
thank you for asking and thank you for
joining
all right there's some questions about
psychedelics and psychosis
uh
schizophrenia etc
i absolutely do not recommend
psychedelics if you have had multiple
psychotic episodes
or if you have history
uh family history of schizophrenia or
personal experiences with with uh
schizophrenia or
uh multiple personality disorder or
anything like that
these compounds
can absolutely in
from what i've seen and also this is
supported by some degree of of the
research
accelerate the onset of some of these
conditions or exacerbate the symptoms
and severity of some of these conditions
so i absolutely would suggest that
people
who
are
concerned about that not take
psychedelics
and
with respect to my own
manic depression of bipolar disorder
i experience more
uh
symptomatically or sort of
phenomenologically although that's
usually used in the context of fancy
fancy
papers
in my life respect with respect to
psychedelics in terms of the
presentation of symptoms i experience
what resembles more major depressive
disorder or treatment resistant
depression i don't have
much in terms of amplitude change
with manic episodes and i think the more
you experience that
the
higher the danger or the greater the
risks involved i am not suggesting that
anyone with bipolar should use
psychedelics i should also note that i
have access to
pretty much every one of the world's top
experts with respect to psychedelics
chances are that most people listening
to me do not have that degree of
professional guidance
and
input so my suggestion would be if you
have pre-existing
psychiatric conditions that you only
use psychedelics in conjunction with
advice from your psychiatrist and from
your medical doctor and one first step
there is to introduce them to how to
change your mind book by michael pollan
and if they're willing to read that
since i think also psychedelics
represent the
possible
i shouldn't say the future of psychiatry
but a future
paradigm that will dramatically change
the nature of psychiatric treatment
and
also overlap with i think in some cases
medical treatment if you look at some of
the beta-carbolines in ayahuasca for
instance like harmy and i think there
are tremendous
possible applications to
what we might consider physiological
illnesses right physical illnesses ibs
crohn's and so on
or neurological damage
experienced by
those
who suffer from chronic depression etc
but this is all a very long way of
saying if you have a preexisting
psychiatric condition do not use
psychedelics without
discussing this and without the support
and guidance of your psychiatrist as
well as your medical doctor because
whether you're on medication or not
there are significant risks
and if you swim a little closer
to
the bank of chaos
and entropy than the bank of rigidity
and i had a conversation with graham
duncan about this on the podcast but if
you if you flow in this direction you
can get yourself into a lot of trouble
with psychedelics and
uh my cousin by marriage actually
used a lot of lsd when he was young and
there are some in the family who think
that that precipitated early onset of
schizophrenic symptoms and is very very
very challenging
he's fortunately
doing extremely well now but
these are things you should be very
careful with
so
cautionary notes complete but work with
your psychiatrist and your doctor and
you do need both
okay
take a look at some more of the live
questions
okay ranjit singh am i still interested
in bitcoin crypto yes i'm still very
interested in crypto and blockchain
although there is a sea of noise and
garbage out there
all right question
here what do you think about the incerto
or maybe it's concerto by nassim
nicholas taleb i haven't read
the incerto or incerto i'm not sure how
to pronounce that honestly but i
have read
the black swan fooled by randomness and
some of his other writing and i find it
tremendously compelling
so i have
not dug into enchierto or the uncertain
seroto
so i have no opinion of that but
antifragile
fooled by randomness and the black swan
not necessarily in that order i found
all of them to be very thought-provoking
and worth reading and i don't say that
lightly
all right
let's see what else we got
okay guys bear with
actually somebody pointed this out and i
should highlight it kevin rose also has
a fantastic podcast called modern
finance i think it's modern.finance on
the web you can find it wherever you
find your podcasts i think it's at
modern underscore phi on twitter but it
is exceptional with respect to
defy and
new innovations in the world of finance
banking money et cetera
uh let me take a look at a few more of
these and i'll probably
hop off and maybe 15-20 minutes if
that's okay with you guys
even if it's not okay with you guys i'm
gonna do that
all right
all right here's a good question and
it's it's related to my disclaimer and
warning earlier linda e robledo i found
myself asking if the subconscious should
always be examined if we are functioning
are we prepared to open pandora's box
with the use of psychedelic treatment
options it seems very scary to me and
not sure why it will repression rear its
ugly head later this is a great question
and commentary
always is a really strong word and i
think it's it's aptly used here right
so
should we always examine the
subconscious if we're functioning
if you are highly functioning
and
things are going well
i it would be hard for me to say that
you should automatically
use psychedelics or that you have to use
psychedelics they are not a panacea
there are risks involved and
you can open up pandora's box and
experience things
that will require processing so if you
don't have space in your life to do that
if you don't have slack in the system to
contend with material that might come up
then
you should consider very carefully
whether or not this is a good time or if
there is any good time for you to use
these compounds i am not
a
messiah at all i don't view myself as a
hammer looking
for nails with psychedelics they are
contraindicated in many circumstances
they are extremely powerful
people who take them lightly generally
get punished
and you can have long-term consequences
that are very difficult to resolve and
if you're cavalier with some of these
compounds even if they have short
duration in earth time like 5-0 dmt and
15 minutes five to 15 minutes and people
refer to it as the business man's high
the businessman's trip
this is a
dramatic underestimation of just how
destabilizing
and reorienting or disorienting these
comp counts can be they're very very
powerful so
i continue to feel that they are
and will be as important as
stan groff has said as important to
psychiatry and the understanding of the
mind as the microscope was to biology
and the telescope was to astronomy i
believe that i completely believe that
both from firsthand experience and from
the research and from anecdotal reports
in great numbers
and right along with that you can
inflict upon yourself
instability or ontological shock that is
incredibly difficult to contend with
so
i don't think that one should always
open up pandora's box with these
compounds uh nor do i think that
everyone should use them
even once
and you know for many of these reasons i
also think it's a great
it's a great
state of affairs and a great
place right now with respect to phase 3
trials to have mdma assisted
psychotherapy as the tip of the spear
because
mdma
is a compound in the right context with
properly trained therapists that is much
easier to facilitate and to navigate
also to prepare for and to integrate
than classic psychedelics
or novel
newer synthetic psychedelics so i'm very
pleased
that we will hopefully have
time with larger numbers of patients to
refine the systems and
the way
in which these substances are
administered the way that adverse events
are dealt with
uh with mdma before even psilocybin i'm
very very
pleased by that
okay casey mercil
what do you do to pattern interrupt when
you notice you're slipping into a low
point i find
often that the fall gains momentum and i
would be curious how to hedge against
this there are a couple of really simple
things
and
it's easy to neglect simple
the obvious seems
perhaps
less like a secret
because of course it isn't a secret
but the fundamentals i should say
exercise in the morning getting out in
the sun first five to 20 minutes
putting off caffeine for 60 to 90
minutes so you don't over caffeinate and
therefore given the half-life and
quarter life of caffeine interrupt your
sleep
using different tools to improve your
sleep quality and track your sleep
quality you don't have to necessarily
spend money on this but eat sleep for
instance or ring for tracking these are
things that i use
exercise in ensuring that you are
exercising enough that you are
physically tired when you get into bed
uh
and then
there there are personally ways in which
i micro dose i'm going to put
psychedelics aside because i don't want
to give any prescriptive advice related
to psychedelics
but
you could also microdose as was
recommended to me by a very very
well-respected doctor i know
with the approval of your doctor i'm not
providing medical advice so please speak
to your medical professional about this
low dose lithium orotate which i
purchase on amazon and i take five
milligrams before bed and if i'm
starting to slip or feel like i might be
slipping i take five milligrams in the
morning as well
that is not a monotherapy or high dose
this is not
lithium at 1500 milligrams or something
like that lithium can produce very
significant side effects especially in
high doses i take it at very low doses
to effectively mimic
or i should say enact the takeaways from
an article i read a long time ago in the
new york times which was sent to me
called something like you'll be able to
find it
maybe we all just need a little bit of
lithium and it talked about the inverse
correlation of groundwater lithium
levels
and
hospital admissions
uh of
psychotic episodes uh cause of death
attributed to suicide things like that
but certainly read the article and speak
to your medical professional but
don't forget the basics
exercise
sun
mitigating caffeine cutting out alcohol
that's a big one
and uh also cold exposure
there are i think very legitimate
reasons why back in the day
people like van gogh would be prescribed
two cold baths per day
because it does have at least in my case
significant antidepressant effects and
anxiolytic effects that would be
anti-anxiety effects so those are a few
okay
aha
so for clarity
tim the enchanto i'm assuming it's
concerto since he likes italian is the
collection of the following books fooled
by randomness the black swan
anti-fragile
some will include skin in the game great
then i'm a fan of the collection there
you have it
all right lauren o'brien has a question
do you have plans to engage congress and
federal changes related to psychedelics
or is that a longer-term objective once
the science is solid
uh i will be enabling other people
to do both of these simultaneously so
the answer is
both end
i think that
furthering the science is critically
important on many levels and then
there's
policy legal and separately advocacy
work that can be done and education that
can be done
and thankfully there are
some figures
former
political powerhouses and current who
are
very much
paying attention to
psychedelic therapies and how they can
be applied to certain populations who
are
politically immune in some respects like
veterans with complex ptsd and i'm
absolutely fine uh more than fine with
starting with that subpopulation because
it's it's important to have
defensive capabilities or better yet
sort of political immunity meaning that
neither party no member of any political
party can say [ __ ] the veterans
and get away with it uh it's just not
gonna work so they have
uh in that sense an immunity
idol or talisman
that enables them
to further certain types of
investigation
in a way that is very difficult
otherwise
so i will be pursuing all of that
here's a question what's your favorite
wrestling movie did you ever watch
vision quest oh yeah vision quest is
fantastic i mean it's
for people now i think it's going to age
probably quite poorly it's pretty cheese
ball but fantastic movie i loved it when
i saw it my favorite wrestling movie
is a documentary called dan gable
competitors supreme
and if you can find it
uh that was my
that was my press play watch to the end
and then start over and press play this
was back when it was vhs and then later
i got the dvd but dan gable competitor
supreme
is about dan gable one of the most
dominant athletes of all time
who
i'm gonna get this wrong but he had a
high school and college record of
something like 253
and zero and then in his i want to say
his last match in his
last ncaa final he lost by one point
and he was
so
upset by this
that he trained seven hours a day seven
days a week for the munich olympics and
then won a gold medal i want to say
without having a single point scored on
him
now that's enough to make you a legend
but then dan gable went on to become a
coach and to become
i don't know now there are john smith
and there are many other coaches
uh who have done amazing amazing things
so i'm not sure if this still stands but
certainly for a while he was one of the
most dominant
coaches
not just in wrestling but in any sport
he produced
just an endless string of championships
and champions so dan gable competitors
supreme i haven't seen it in many years
but
if you have a chance to watch it check
it out and let me know what you think
it's intense and it's great i really
really really enjoyed it
okay
all right jonas k what gets most people
the most bang for the buck in terms of
time management when you exceed 200k
annual income example given executive
assistance
whether it's 200k or less or more i
think it becomes increasingly important
to
revisit certain concepts the way i do
that is through books
so the effective executive by peter
drucker read that read it at least once
a year
essentialism by greg mcewen
read that
highlight it highlight it on a kindle so
you can export your highlights and then
review your highlights
another would be the 80 20 principle
and if you're still inclined the
four-hour workweek because
there are there are there's a certain
synthesis of a lot of those in the
four-hour workweek but i don't read my
own book
because that would be
[ __ ] bizarre so i don't read my own
book
be really really strange to be spotted
walking around reading my own book at
restaurants and so on so
i read that's not the only reason i mean
i already know that content so i'm going
back to catch things that perhaps i
didn't catch the first time or to review
my own highlights in all of those books
those are a few
all right two more questions from the
submitted questions
it's from michael friedman or fridman
could you please give some examples
about how having a sleep tracker helped
improve your sleep i'm on the fence
about buying the one that you have had
for a while and a little push would be
great thanks a lot for all your amazing
work i've been a huge fan
for over 10 plus years thank you michael
for most people who use a sleep tracker
many of the takeaways will be obvious
so if you use say or a ring
which i still use uh
because i do constant experimentation
and i like to see what happens for
instance without the aura ring i would
not have realized that
if i have a sauna right before bed or
too late at night within three hours of
going to sleep it interferes with sleep
and also negatively impacts hiv the next
day however
if i have a sauna
at say four or five pm
a few hours before dinner it
dramatically improves
hrv for the next day or two
uh also something that nearly everyone
will see is
that two or more alcoholic drinks if
you're drinking stiff drinks like gin
and soda as i often do might be only one
drink
dramatically damages your sleep quality
and for me that's especially true of
deep sleep and
i find
that to be valuable
as a reminder even though it is obvious
and it it makes self denial or denial of
that very very hard and i would say that
overall the main benefit of wearing a
tracker is it makes you more aware of
your sleep and it facilitates it
encourages paying more attention to your
sleep
so honestly even if the only thing i got
from wearing an aura ring was seeing it
on my hand and thinking about my sleep
and knowing that i shouldn't have that
second
glass of wine or that second
gin and soda or whatever the alcoholic
beverage might be
it would pay for itself
a thousand times over in my life
and there are certainly other devices
but
eight sleep helps to track it also helps
to modify right because of the way that
it provides cooling and heating
depending on the zone on the bed there
are other options of course
and then you have many different
tracking devices my favorite being the
aura
o-u-r-a ring
but
could you improve your sleep could you
become aware of these things without
those
yes
can you modify
yes you can still modify your sleep
but there's certain things technically
that are a lot easier with something
like eight sleep or the
chili pad things of that type
all right i'm gonna do one more
wesley awry you're highly efficient seem
to be knowledgeable about everything you
do
is there anything that you do that you
just say f it and do it willy nilly
that's a good question
so first of all i'm picking the
questions that i answer so that creates
the
illusion that i'm knowledgeable about
everything that i do so i am i'm
curating these questions i'm not
answering the questions that would leave
me stuttering and giving nonsense
answers or making things up so that's an
illusion
i appreciate the the comment nonetheless
is there anything that i do just to say
[ __ ] it and do it willy-nilly yeah tons
of stuff there's lots of stuff uh all
over the place uh so if you know i went
boating recently
tried to learn how to sail uh you didn't
know what i was doing at all but i had a
great time you know i had a few drinks
with friends uh
on the water and it was it was fantastic
had a lot of fun uh
so when i am invited to do new things
uh i'm constantly just saying [ __ ] it
playing with new instruments musical
instruments [ __ ] it let's play around
i'm not putting it into some
you know
dss framework and sitting down and
saying hold on hold on i'm not going to
jam with you guys give me give me two
hours to figure this out and watch
youtube videos i'm not doing that
and it might be the only time that i
play around but i do certainly play
around and it's important to me for my
personal growth that i do more of that
so thank you for the
for the reminder
and uh the last question is gonna be the
last ones i think it's a good one to end
on this is from brandon beckett i
practice mindfulness in gratitude
but still can't find a way to temper my
drive feel satisfied and enjoy the
present moment how do i slow down and
enjoy life again without being so
focused
on the future
okay so if i take a look at this there
are two things that jump out at me
and
the first is you say
and enjoy life again what that implies
to me
is that you have enjoyed life before in
other words what you're striving to be
able to do you've already done at some
point so i think journaling on that
even if it's several days in a row in
the morning long hand stream of
consciousness
something along the lines of morning
pages
and i suggest you just look up my name
and morning pages and that'll give you a
lot
on
how i think about these things and use
these things
that would be step number one
although
this can be done simultaneously with
step number two which is
really simple
read an article called the tail end by
tim urban so tim urban has
a
blog although he's calling it a blog
seems to not give it sufficient gravitas
his website is called wait but why
and you can find it weight butt y
spelled out weight but w-h-y dot com
and there's an article called the tail
end
which everyone should read and
that was introduced to me by matt
mullenweg
and
it really changed how i look at the
world and how i look at my life because
it shares with you multiple ways of
visualizing
your remaining time on the planet
visually your remaining time with loved
ones visually
and it is a gut punch
it is a sober
and catalyzing
reminder it is very short as an article
and i have read that probably 20 times
it is incredibly good it's so good that
i believe that
tim urban very graciously allowed me to
reproduce it in
either tools of titans or tribe of
mentors
that is how strongly i felt about it but
you must if you have not read the tale
end by tim urban and if you've read it
print it out read it again
read it every morning it is that
powerful
and with that
i will
wish you all a wonderful week and a
wonderful weekend
thank you for joining everyone this has
been a lot of fun for me so hopefully
it's been fun for other people as well
and
let's do this again
tea time with tim is my tea time with
all of you and i enjoy it very very much
and i will include links to everything
discussed in the show notes which people
can find
when this is published at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast
and until next time
thank you for tuning in be safe
experiment constantly and i don't mean
necessarily with drugs i mean with
behaviors with getting sun in the
morning with trying cold exposure
and
accepting what you find useful rejecting
what you find useless and adding what is
uniquely your own allah bruce lee
baby steps baby steps
that is from what about bob
one of the greatest philosophical movies
of all time and with that i bid you
adieu
you